- Powerful subtraction helps put your app on the path to success.
In this video we present ten tips
You can get a great launch for your app.
You need a wonderful application so you get a great put up.
Make sure your application is up to a good level
By testing its compliance with our Android quality guidelines
Via developers.android.com
Then, see the instructions for each dimension
Which provides support,
Including Tablet PC, TV, Wear, and Auto.
Age App evaluation helps users around the world
In ensuring that your content is relevant.
After completing the questionnaire
Your app's age range will be evaluated.
Local assessments that are popular with the local audience will be provided
Important markets around the world.
The Play Store card is an integral part of
Marketing application.
Show your audience the way they're displayed on their devices
Using icons, screenshots, graphics, and videos.
Prepare experiments with store cards in the developer console
To test different graphics and texts as soon as possible
Even provide improvements through data in the data card.
Set up applications in the local user language
Increases the chance of downloading.
So be sure to translate the descriptive text of your listing
Do not forget to translate the text of screenshots and graphics
And videos as well.
You can use the application translation service
In the app developer console.
Many users are targeting them
From a limited data connection therefore you get applications
Which are characterized by small APKs have a large download rate.
You can reduce the APK size
By removing the associated unused items in the library,
Application of animation and appropriate code,
And provide resources for common congestion situations only in the screen.
It is necessary to test how applications work
And pre-roll performance testing.
Be sure to test on the most common devices in target markets.
Ask for help from the users forum
By signing up for a trial use.
And participate in the Cloud Test Lab within the Developer Console
To automatically test your experiment
On hundreds of common devices
You will get a detailed analysis of any problems.
When launching a new application or a new game, interest will arise between
Target users and current users.
Be sure not to miss this opportunity.
The opportunity may be lost if they can not get
On the application or update it in one time with everyone.
Keep the app launch momentum on Android,
Taking into account all dimensions at the same time
With other platforms,
Or try telling users who have other platforms
That support would be available soon and provided them with a means of receiving notice.
Newspapers and blogs are always looking for good content,
So tell the newspapers and blogs as soon as possible.
Prepare a list of local and global contacts.
Find bloggers for apps and games,
But do not forget to target placement publications as well.
If you have an app for flights, for example,
Do not forget to include flyers.
Create a press pack.
Use screenshots and a summary of your app or game,
In addition to a graphic presentation that shows how distinctive and attractive the content is,
And mention something interesting about your company.
Marketing your app greatly helps you differentiate between
Crowds of applications.
Make a plan to use social networks,
Video content,
App install ads, and more.
Keep interest in the application still in place
By continuing to emphasize it strongly.
Try presentations and incentives
And reminders on special events and events.
After you publish your app, expect questions from users,
And the problems they face in use want you to solve them.
There are several ways to address this:
Monitor the contact email in your app listing
On the Play Store, and create a Google group where users can post
Questions about support, and try using a third-party customer support product.
Responding helps users keep interacting
It provides you with customer loyalty you need.
For more information about putting your app up,
You can go to the distribution section
On the Android Android Developer site,
You can also check the subtraction checklist.
If you want to get more tips on how to improve performance
Your application or game and improve your work in applications,
You can see the videos in the series
Download the "Google Play App Success Secrets" guide.